lectures ont été entendus et pendant 20
secondes ce qui a semblé beaucoup plus
long ce n'est pas une bonne idée d'être
inédit cette époque là les titres de
l'actrice doute avec réseau temps on
était un exotisme à croquer les
québécois sont ré en disant oui et des
techniques avec la consommation chaque
nation au développement éducation
[Musique]
un axe groupe de musique achetée à
l'époque la province de québec au nissan
chansons j'étais résidents chirurgie
elle à l'hôtel dieu de montréal au mois
de juillet mais sa green fees je le fais
tu ne vas pas de famille je vais me fais
de 4 à ce moment là j'ai deux soudeurs
et à l'époque je travaillais dans une
institution financière à oka
[Musique]
l'histoire
on a été retiré des hommes les ondes de
radio commerciaux à m'attriste encore
aujourd'hui parce que on a été retirée
des ondes
on n'est jamais revenu à chaque jour
avec un jeune des femmes comme sentais
comme écrasé je suis pointé du doigt
comme responsables de la crise actuelle
les gars de mon âge un petit peu plus
vieux se quitter tous deux en attente
des cicatrices de ce taux
et en a beaucoup d'entre nous qui on
aurait construit liés
les problèmes qui ont véhicule depuis ce
temps le même mois
[Musique]
je me rappelle encore et c'était
dégueulasse où on avait permis aux aînés
et aux gens malades des cannois qui de
sortir de la communauté et les gens sont
sortis dans une histoire le second est
escorté par la police et les gens de
ville lasalle ou lancer des cailloux sur
les vite sur les autos les anime déjà
malade le beaucoup de gens qui essaient
de prendre la cuisse boucau même
aujourd'hui et de romantisme la crise et
je peux vous assurer qu'ils veulent y
ait des romantiques de scouts et sue la
crise qu'est-ce que ça va pas ça le
sensibiliser au fait qu' ils y ont des
revendications qu'il faut écouter qu'ils
font entendre qu'il faut travailler il à
cuiseaux fait que une fermeture totale
en mai reculé de 36,38 or on est encore
[Musique]
espérons que nous espérons qu'on va
avoir des gens assez ouvert et à ces
contrées aussi pourquoi puisque éviter
ce genre de crise on n'a rien fait
depuis 90 on a fait grand chose depuis
96 de plus elle comme son espèce de sous
on a fait cap sur place et le surplace
en rien de la misère sociale qui n est
que de la poudre aux caisses la bombe
une autre
on vit toujours avec la possibilité
qu'une autre
une crise éclate
lorsqu'on au pot a pris une bonne leçon
et les gouvernements surtout n'ont pas
appris les bonnes leçons de la crise et
on continue à répéter les mêmes erreurs
qui ont mené à la crise
force est de constater qu'après mène 30
1 il ya rien de réglé mais sachant
aujourd'hui comment les communautés
autochtones veulent fonctionner avec le
monde à l'automne
c'est beaucoup beaucoup dans le dialogue
dans le respect donc très qu'aujourd'hui
n'aurait plus deuxième crise comme qu'on
ait eue il ya 30 ans
[Musique]
moi je peux laisser un héritage à mes
enfants je veux pas leurrer c'est une
course fantastique
je veux leur laisser une contrée dessus
si ce que je suis allée de la main avec
les revendications territoriales qui
sont qui ne sont pas réglés
ils servent à soissons territorial
permettrait de développer un levier eux
mêmes et pour les premières nations ont
juste pas mon couleur nous enfin une
utilisation pour pouvoir essayer de
régler ses problèmes d'eau
ils réglés avec compréhension compassion
il faut apprendre de l'autre pour pas
voir pas mais il faut aussi tout passe
par l'éducation qui passe par là il faut
une ouverture mais une version des deux
côtés il faut avoir cette ouverture ou
venus nous voir comme nous on est très à
l'étroit
[Musique]